it has been an extraordinary difficult
time for everyone in Health and Care
flu has made this winter particularly
tough first because we're facing the
worst flu season for 10 years the number
of people in hospital with flu this time
last year was 50. this year it was over
5100.
next because it came early and came
quickly increasing Sevenfold between
November and December
it also came when GPS and primary care
and Community Care were at their most
constrained and just as flu affects the
population it also affects the workforce
too leading to staff sickness absence
that constrains Supply just at the same
time as it also increases demand
because these flu pressures come on top
of covid with over 9 000 people in
hospital we covered while exceptional
levels of scarlet fever activity and an
increase in strep a has created further
pressure on a and e
and all of this of course comes on top
of a high historic starting point
so we didn't have a quiet Summer with
the significant levels of covid and
delayed discharges were more than double
what they were during the pandemic so to
put this in context for the house in
June 2020 there were just 6 000 cases of
delayed discharge per day those patients
ready to leave Hospital who are
medically fit to do so whereas
throughout last year it was between 12
and 13
000 a day
so Mr Speaker the scale the speed the
timing of our flu season has combined
with the outgoing high level of covid
admissions in hospital and the pandemic
Legacy of high delay discharge to put
real strain on Frontline services
Mr Speaker since the NHS began preparing
for this winter there was a recognition
that this year had the potential to be
the hardest ever
that is why there was a specific focus
on vaccination
there were 9 million flu shots in 70
million Autumn boosters we extended
eligibility more widely than in the past
to cover the over 50s and became the
first place in the world to have the
bivalent covid vaccine which tackles
both the omicon train and the original
covid stream
NHS England also put in place plans for
the equivalent of 7 000 additional beds
including the introduction of virtual
Awards of the sort one can see at
Watford General Hospital
and that Innovation is still at an early
stage of development but has the
potential to be significant in reducing
pressure on bed occupancy in hospitals
in Watford alone it has saved the
equivalent of an extra Hospital ward of
patients
in addition our plan for patients put
500 million specifically into delayed
discharge with a further 600 million
next year and 1 billion the year after
and while the funds are already starting
to make a difference efforts have taken
time to ramp up operationally with local
authorities and the local NHS
in addition our 42 integrated care
boards recognizing how bad occupancy in
hospitals and social care are connected
will fully integrate Health and Care in
the years to come but likewise or at an
early stage of maturity with icbs only
becoming fully operationalized in July
2022 so less than six months ago
so Mr Speaker our plans involving
integration of hospital care and social
care additional funding into discharge
increased step down capacity the
equivalent of seven thousand additional
hospital beds
and a vaccination program at scale have
provided groundwork for the government
response
but it is clear we need to do more right
now in light of the level of flu and
covid rates and given Hospital occupancy
remains far too high and emergency
departments are too congested
recognizing this we launched the
elective recovery task force on the 7th
of December and in the coming weeks we
will publish our urgent and Emergency
Care recovery plans and NHS England and
Department of Health and Social care
have been working intensively over
Christmas on these plans which were
reviewed with Health and Care leaders
and that NHS recovery Forum in down the
street on Saturday
the recovery falls into three main areas
of work
first steps to support the system now
given the immediate pressures we face
this winter
second steps to support a whole
assistant response this year to give
better resilience during the summer and
Autumn because as we saw with the heat
wave this summer and the levels of Kobe
pressure is now sustained throughout the
year not just as in the past during
autumn and winter periods and third I
work alongside these two areas on
prevention
to maximize the step change prevention
potential of proven Technologies such as
work virtual Awards and The Wider
adoption of Innovations such as
operational control centers and machine
reading software to treat more
conditions in the community away from
reaching the emergency department in the
first place
Mr Speaker let me set out the first of
these with the measures I can announce
today to provide support to the NHS and
local authorities now
first we will block book beds in
residential homes to enable around 2 500
people to be released from hospitals
where they are medically fit to be
discharged when combined with the
ramping up of the 500 million discharge
funding
it will unblock which will unblock an
estimated one to two thousand delayed
discharge cases capacity on Wards will
be freed up which in turn enables those
patients omitted by emergency
departments to move towards which in
turn unblocks ambulance delays
it is important however that we learn
from the deployments of a similar
approach during the pandemic by ensuring
the right wraparound care is provided
for those patients released to
Residential Care
which I have asked NHS England to
particularly focus on
so it is the shortest possible stay on
their journey home and into domiciliary
care and indeed it is in the nhs's own
interests for those days to be as short
as possible
taken together this is a 200 million
pound investment over the next three
months
next uh a E's are also under particular
strain
from my visits across the country I've
seen and heard how they often need more
space to enable same-day emergency care
and short stays post emergency
department
so our second investment today is more
physical capacity in and around
emergency departments
by using modular units this capacity
will be available in weeks not months
and our 50 million investment will focus
on modular support this year and we will
apply funding for next year's allocation
to significantly expand this program
ahead of the summer
we are giving trust discretion on how
best to use these units to decompress
their emergency departments so that
might be spaces for short stay post a e
care where there's no need for the
patient to go to award for further
observation
or for discharge lounges where
previously they're not being able to
take patients in a bed many of those who
often simply chairs and also additional
capacity alongside the emergency
department at the front end of the
hospital
Mr Speaker the third action we are
taking to support the system right now
is to free up Frontline stuff from being
diverted by CQC inspections over the
coming weeks and the CQC have agreed to
reduce inspections and focus on high
risk providers in other settings like
Mental Health
Mr Speaker those are the actions we're
taking that will have an immediate
effect
turning now to the measures we're taking
now that will give greater resilience
into this summer and next winter
we now have 42 NHS system control
centers in operations uh across England
staff 24 hours a day some days a week
tracking patients on their Journeys
through hospitals and helping us
identify blockages earlier and getting
through uh flow through the systems
where we have implemented these systems
such as the one I saw in operation in
Maidstone they have had a clear impact
so we're going to allocate funding in
next year's settlement to apply this
more widely
similar to this we've also seen how the
use of artificial intelligence and data
can demonstrably reduce demand and
release patients sooner
NHS England has been tasked with
clarifying and simplifying this
procurement landscape
taken on board best International
practice so that a small number of scale
of interventions are taken forward where
International experience shows they can
deliver meaningful benefits to patients
next Mr Speaker we will capitalize on
the incredible potential of virtual
Awards
last week at Watford General Hospital I
saw how patients have been in hospital
beds were treated at home through a
combination of technology and wrap
around care
where patients released sooner were
often much happier knowing they're
receiving clinical supervision and
always have the safety nets of being
able to quickly return to hospital
should their contusion deteriorate
there is scope to expand this to many
more conditions and many more hospitals
in the months ahead
next Mr Speaker we are opening up more
routes for NHS patients to get free
treatment in the independent sector and
offering even greater patient choice
the elective recovery task force is
helping us find spare operating theaters
hospital beds and outpatient capacity
there are also steps we must take in
Primary Care
we are clear there are many more things
our community pharmacists can support
with which will ease pressure on general
practice
from the end of March Community
pharmacists will take referrals from
urgent and Emergency Care settings and
later this year we will also start
offering oral contraceptive services but
I want to do even more and indeed as
they do in Scotland and we will work
with Community pharmacists to Tuggle
barriers to offering more services
including how we better use Digital
Services
the primary care recovery plan was set
out a range of additional service
Services
pharmacists can deliver
finally Mr Speaker notwithstanding the
very severe pressures we know that to
break the cycle of the NHS repeatedly
coming under severe pressure the best
way to reduce the numbers through our
front doors is to address problems away
from the emergency department itself
on Friday we signed a memorandum of
understanding we buy on Tech a global
leader in mlna technology to bring
vaccine research to this country
this will give as many as 10 000 UK
patients Early Access to trials for
personalized cancer therapies by 2030.
this Builds on the 10-year partnership
we struck with moderna in December to
also invest in our Mona r d in the UK
and to build state-of-the-art vaccine
manufacturing here
we're also reviewing our wider care for
the frail elderly patients in Care Homes
long before they would ever get to a e
or in our hospitals take for example the
brilliant work they're doing in teas
Valley where they're using Community
teams to help with Falls to prevent
unnecessary ambulance trips to hospitals
and we have looked at what more support
we can offer elderly patients further
Upstream with an aging population and
many more people with more than one
condition it is clear we have to treat
patients earlier in the community and go
beyond individual Specialties to better
reflect patients with multiple
conditions and indeed to give the right
support to people where they are which
is often at home or in residential homes
Mr Speaker today's announcements
provides a further 250 million pounds of
funding which recognizes that the spike
in flu on top of covered Emissions on
top of high delay discharge numbers from
the pandemic will provide immediate
support to reduce hospital bed occupancy
and decompress a e pressures and in turn
unlock much needed ambulance handovers
this Builds on the 500 million announced
for discharge specifically at the Autumn
statement which is ramping up and the
additional funding for next year
all of this work ultimately Builds on
the much needed greater integration
between Health and Social care through
the 42 integrated care boards which will
we will strengthen through the shuitt
review
and through a step changing capability
including operational control centers
this immediate and near-term action sits
in parallel with our wider life science
investment such as those deals with bio
and Tech and moderna and underscores our
commitment to bridge recognizing the
immediate pressures on the NHS and
investing in the science that will shift
the dial on earlier Upstream treatment
at scale particularly for the frail
elderly and long before a patient
reaches an emergency department this is
Mr Speaker a comprehensive package of
measures and I commend this statement to
the house we don't come to Shadow
Secretary of State
to come forward we're streaming
thank you Mr Speaker and a Happy New
Year to you and to the rest of the house
and I thank the health secretary for
advanced sight of his statement Mr
Speaker this winter has seen patients
waiting hours on end for an ambulance a
e departments overflowing with patients
and dedicated NHS staff driven to
Industrial action in The Case of the
nurses for the first time in their
history because the government has
failed to listen and to lead I noticed
the Secretary of State didn't take a
moment to talk about the abysmal failure
of his talks with nurses and paramedic
Representatives today so let me say to
him every canceled operation delayed
appointments and ambulance disruption
due to strikes could have been avoided
if he had just agreed to talk to NHS
staff about pay today he could have
opened serious talks to avert further
strikes instead he offered nurses and
paramedics 45 minutes of lip service if
patients suffer further strike action
they will know exactly who to blame but
of course the Prime Minister has already
shown that he's not interested in
solving problems he resorts to the Smoke
stream of parliamentary game playing by
bringing in legislation to SAC NHS staff
for going on strike so let me ask the
Secretary of State in in these NHS
sucking the staff Bill how many nurses
is he planning to stack how many
paramedics is he going to sack how many
Junior doctors is he going to sack and
this government has the audacity to ask
NHS staff for minimum service levels
when are we going to see minimum service
levels from government ministers in the
entire Government after arriving at the
derriford hospital in Plymouth an 83
year old dementia patient waited in the
back of an ambulance outside a e for 26
hours before being admitted this was the
23rd of December where no strikes were
taking place the minister should listen
his family found him in urine soaked
sheets and since arriving in hospital
he's contracted flu his daughter said of
the hospital staff and I quote they're
polite they're caring and they are
trying their best it's just impossible
for them to do the work they want to do
so let me say what the health secretary
and prime minister refused to admit the
NHS is in crisis the biggest crisis in
its history it it is clear to the staff
who have been slogging their guts out
over Christmas it is clear to everyone
who uses the NHS as a patient the only
people who can't see it are the
government what has been announced today
is yet another sticking plaster when the
NHS needs fundamental reform the front
door to the NHS is blocked the exit door
is blocked and there simply aren't
enough staff so where is his plan to fix
primary care so that patients can see
the GP they want in the manner they
choose after 13 years of conservative
government they don't have one where is
his plan to recruit the care workers
needed to care for patients once they've
been discharged from hospitals and to
pay them fairly so that we don't lose
them to other employers after 13 years
of conservative government they don't
have one and where is his plan to train
the doctors and nurses and health
professionals the NHS needs after 13
years of conservative of government they
don't have one well we do Mr Speaker and
he is welcome to Nick Labor's plan to
abolish the non-dom tax status and train
seven and a half thousand more doctors
every year ten thousand more nurses and
midwives every year double the number of
District nurses and provide 5 000 more
Health visitors a plan a plan so good Mr
Speaker the chance for himself admitted
the conservative government should Nick
it yeah yeah but after 13 years of
mismanagement underfunding and costly
top-down reorganizations all the
conservatives have to offer the NHS is a
meeting and photo op in Downing Street
the collapse of the Health Service this
winter could be seen coming from a mile
away Health and Social care leaders were
warning about it last summer so why are
the measures he set out today being
announced in the middle of January why
have Care Homes and local authorities
been made to wait till this month for
the delayed discharge fund to reach them
it's simply too little too late for so
many patients and in fact this
government is so last minute that after
announcing this plan last night they
found an extra 50 million pounds and
sent out another press release now I
know most of us are happy to find a
spare fiver lying around the house we
didn't know was there this prime
minister seems to have 50 million quids
stuck down the back of the sofa what on
Earth is going on no wonder they can't
get money to the front line the left
hand doesn't know what the right hand is
doing and Mr Speaker this is intolerable
for patients who are fit and ready to
leave Hospital who are then stuck there
for months because the care they need
isn't available to the community they're
not bed blockers and Mr Speaker they are
not an inconvenience to be dropped off
at a hotel and forgotten about they need
Rehabilitation at home rather than a bed
in a care facility vulnerable patients
deserve proper support suited around
their needs or they'll fall ill again
and go back to hospital and what about
all these beds the NHS is procuring what
about the capacity that families need
I'll tell you what will happen they
won't get the care and they'll be coming
right back through the front door of the
a e that the cycle of broken systems
repeating themselves again and again and
Mr Speaker where is the choice and
control for patients and their families
who may not want to be discharged to a
hotel I'm afraid Mr Speaker after 13
years this just isn't good enough the
Prime Minister might not rely on the NHS
but millions of ordinary people do they
are sick and they are tired of waiting
and look 13 years of conservative
government now 13 years and look at what
they have done to the NHS did the health
secretary listen to himself has he
described the situation in hospitals of
people waiting on chairs for discharge
sees the trolleys in the corridors and
people waiting longer than ever whose
fault is it not the NHS staff is
threatening to sack Mr Speaker it's the
conservative ministers who've made
disaster after disaster after 13 years
of conservative government it's clear
the longer they are in power the longer
patients will wait only labor can give
the NHS the fresh start and fresh ideas
it needs
well Mr C he talks about a fresh start
but even his own shallow cabinet
colleagues don't seem to agree with his
plan his own Deputy seemed to distance
herself from his plans to use the
private sector and his own shadow
Chancellor seems to distance herself
from his plans for GPS and perhaps he
can share with the house exactly how
much his unfunded plans for GPS will
cost because the chief exec of the
nuffield trust has said quote it will
cost a fortune and are based on an
out-of-date view so the point is he has
no plans that is Deputy and his own
colleagues support and he has notes
about how he would fund those plans in a
way that would not divert the fact that
the NHS in Wales the NHS in Scotland
indeed Health Systems across the globe
have faced significant pressure as a
result of the combination of covid Spite
and and flu spikes particularly in
recent weeks this is not a phenomenon
that is limited to England and the NHS
this is a pressure that has been
reflected internationally including for
the NHS in Wales he refers to talks with
the trade unions and it is right that we
are engaging with the trade unions I was
pleased to meet the staff Council in the
NHS today and indeed the chair of the
NHS staff Council Sarah Gordon said the
discussions had made progress not we
stand in one Trade union leader who was
an in the talks given an interview
outside the department to comment on
what had and had not been said in those
talks but we want to work constructively
with the trade unions on that
um he says that we are only announcing
measures today Mr Speaker but again he
seems to have written those comments
before he got a copy of the speech the
integrated care boards uh took
operational effects in July this year
the Autumn because they are scaling up
we're putting control centers uh in
place we are integrating Health and
Social care we announced in the Autumn
statement Mr Speaker 500 million for
discharge a further 600 million next
year of a billion the year after
recognizing the significant uh pressure
and that is rumping up NHS England sent
out its operational plans in the summer
including 100-day discharge Sprint uh
that set out for example the greater use
of virtual Wars that is new technology
that is being rolled out at scale it
also announced the extra 7000 uh
Community beds and indeed we also set
out in our plan for patients the
additional measures but what is clear
when we have a seven-fold increase in
flu in a month 50 cases emitted last
year compared to 5100 this year you have
a combination of a surge in Supply AI on
top and an existing high level position
and that surging demand
correspondence with a constraint of
Supply because staff absences also
increase because of flu it's during the
Christmas period when community services
are more constrained and those two
together has created very significant
pressure on our lead emergency
departments and that is work right why
through the engagement I have had with
health leaders the two key messages they
gave to me was the importance of getting
flow into hospitals which is constrained
by the High bed occupancy that is why
getting people out of the hospital is so
Central to relieving pressure and
secondly that within the emergency
department specifically we need to
decompress those services and so we're
same day emergency treatment having
short stay post the emergency department
that is a better way to decompress those
emergency departments to through the
triaging and bringing other clinical
Specialties closer to the front door we
have listened to the NHS front line
those were the two key requests that
were made to me alongside other issues
such as CQ inspections and how we Flex
those but we also need to alongside
those immediate pressures recognize that
we had pressures last summer during the
heat wave we had pressures in the Autumn
and that is why we've announced a wider
set of measures today so we have
listened we have acted we've taken
measures to deal with the immediate
pressure but we've also set out how we
will wield further capacity which will
go through into the Autumn and then
alongside that we've signed deals for
example women and bio and Tech and we're
bringing forward the life science
investment so that has a better impact
on pressures on the front line
check the Slate committee Steve bright
thank you very much there's no question
that in some places more than others
patient flow in acute hospitals is the
issue coming up the system the secretary
of state is also right to say that
demand is far outstripping Supply in
part because of the the very high flu
numbers so today's injection of funding
is very welcome as is the additional
surge capacity the Secretary of State
spoke about in his statement I have to
say it's mention of prevention is
especially welcomed by me let's do so
much more on this can I ask my writable
friend because another 250 million
pounds is a lot of the Public's money
what real-time oversight he has to
ensure NHS England spend it wisely can I
just make a plea that domiciliary care
is not overlooked here because the lack
of care in people's homes is every bit
the enemy of patient flow as a lack of
the care home places which is identified
today yeah
well he he raises an extremely important
issue in terms of getting flow into the
system not least because it is delays in
ambulance handovers that leads to the
highest risk in what is a holar system
issue which is that of the patient that
isn't seen uh where treatment is delayed
and that is why flow through discharge
is so important because whilst that
often concerns the the back door of the
hopper still it is actually the pressure
at the front door that is most acute
that's was recognized by the government
in the Autumn statement that's why there
is additional funding with the 500
million for delay discharged that has
taken some time to ramp up what we're
recognizing is because of the flu there
is an immediacy in terms of the pressure
on a e that we need to address his point
though really speaks to one of the key
lessons from the Kobe period which is
not simply about releasing patients from
hospital who are fit to discharge it is
also about the wrap around services that
are provided for those patients so that
they then don't get get stuck in
residential care for longer and they're
still able to go home and get those
dominance delivery care packages and
that is something that NHS England is
particularly focused on so they have the
wrap around Services alongside that
discharge they make Hilliard
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker
and a Happy New Year
Mr Deputy speaker we've seen this year
in year out money thrown into the NHS as
a winter crisis Point too late to spend
it sensibly and yet this government has
been in power for nearly 30 years
reading and listening to the Secretary
of State speech I can't see what's new
in it we've talked about discharge
before and picking up on the point from
the selects the chair of the select
committee without proper funding for
local councils for domiciliary care and
for funding Care Homes this will never
work
well in terms of what is different is
the the block booking that this will
enable which will therefore give the
Residential Care the ability to put in
place the workforce to release that
delayed discharge from 13 000 that are
in hospital who are medically fit to
discharge the acceleration of releasing
those patients will then enable the the
front door where the spiking flu is so
acute to be released so that is what
he's doing and this responds to what
health leaders them say elves have said
is the key intervention we can take but
of course it's not in isolation and the
point is that this comes on top of the
500 million what that was announced uh
join the Autumn statement but this is
additional to give further capacity
recognizing the significant pressure
that the system is under
Australian
you Mr Deputy speaker my right handful
friend is absolutely right to highlight
but this is not as purely an English
issue this is affected Health Systems
Across the Western world and I welcome
many aspects of what he said today I'm
also very grateful to staff at Epsom
hospital and in the ambulance service in
my constituency but so much the time
those paramedics is taking frail elderly
people from Care Homes to a e where
frankly they probably shouldn't be what
steps can he take to divert some of
those for elderly people out of a e take
some of the pressures off and actually
get them to an environment where frankly
it'll be much better looked after
well I think that's where the uh he's
absolutely the right and and that's
where the potential in terms of everyone
looks at virtual Awards virtual Awards
have
um significant benefits both in terms of
demand management uh in avoiding elderly
frail uh patients coming into the
emergency department uh in the first
place but it also releases capacity out
of hospital so if I look at the virtual
world at Watford General Hospital that
was equivalent to an additional ward of
the hospital where it's able to release
patients who have the comfort of knowing
that they're still under supervision
their medical information is being
tracked and monitored they get a daily
phone call from a nurse but they also
know if they need to come back into the
hospital they can do so much more
quickly and that gives people the
comfort and confidence to then recover
at home which is often where the patient
wants to be and indeed the patient
satisfaction from that trial at Watford
was over 90 percent
Ben Bradshaw thank you Mr Deputy uh
speaker given there are currently 165
000 vacancies in Social care a 51
increase in just a year where's he going
to Magic up the people to look after the
people he wants to put in hotels
well the the whole purpose of the 500
million is uh to put more support for
local authorities into their funding in
Social care around a quarter of that
funding is going specifically on
Workforce interventions but we're also
using other measures as well and one of
the other things that we've been doing
is boosting International recruitment as
well uh care sector staff on the
shortage occupation list and that is
another another way that we're boosting
uh Workforce recruitment
Mr Deputy speaker can I welcome the
session of stakes uh statement in
particular the additional money for
discharge but would he agree with me
that in regard to integrative Care
Systems that actually we really do need
to accelerate that integration between
Health and Social care notwithstanding
what he said about maturity that's the
key to the future of the integration of
Health and Social care and we'll solve
many of the problems that we face at the
moment I just said well it is and he's
right and that's why for example in the
events of Christmas one of the
ministerial priorities was meeting we
had a whole series of ministerial
meetings with the chairs and chief execs
of the icbs because it is through that
integration of the 42 integrated care
boards that we will bring Health and
Social care together the government has
recognized that they became
operationally uh in place from July last
year those are ramping up at PACE and
one of the things that's making a real
difference to them is having the the
control centers that allow patient flow
to be tracked through the system
maidstone's very good example of that
and that data is then allowing blockages
in what is a whole assistant problem to
be gripped at a much earlier stage
professional maskel
so watch uh retention is at the heart of
this crisis both in the health sector
and in the social care sector and you
can't retain staff if you don't pay them
and if you don't pay them in this year
they won't address the issues will you
recognize where when he set the remit
for the pay-per-view body inflation
wasn't where it was we didn't have a war
in Ukraine but factors have changed and
therefore the remit must change for pay
within this year so that we retain the
staff to deliver what he's proposes but
the point I met to The Honorable lady is
in terms of delayed discharge the key is
having the domiciliary care support that
is not actually about the NHS agenda for
change contract that is about the
funding for those in the social care
sector around a quarter of delayed
discharge is due to delays in what's
known as pathway one the domicily care
side that is what the 500 million in
particular recognize so we are putting
more money into that but that's about
the social care sector so we can get
flow through delayed discharge
who will also know that in the with some
constituency we have a higher than
national average GP to Patient ratio it
is a major problem for us it has been
for a long time we're short of
diagnostic facilities and of course
Essex County Council also need more
resources to do with adult social care
for the very reasons that my right unbel
friend has spoke about can he let me
know he won't be able to do this from
the dispatch box today but can he tell
me write to me please to give me the
specific details of when on all three of
those areas in Essex we will see the
money that he has announced today
actually come to the front line because
our doctors and nurses need that money
and the resources to do really why what
they joined the profession for which is
to give the care that they really
believe in to members of the public
very happy to write to uh my right to my
friend with it the further details but
just for the benefit of the house in
terms of the 500 million announced in
the Autumn statement local authorities
gave uh the department an NHS England
their data Returns on Friday so we will
have data that I'll be able to share
more specifically in terms of the 500
million in terms of the 250 million
announced today NHS England that is for
a very urgent delivery into systems and
that will be going out uh extremely
quickly Daisy Cooper
Deputy speaker NHS leaders have told the
health services Journal today that the
government has just seven to ten days to
get this additional funding to discharge
hospital patients to the front line for
it to make any difference whatsoever and
the NHS Confederation has said that the
next three months in the NHS will likely
be defined by critical incidents being
declared so will the Secretary of State
promise that this extra funding will
reach the front line in the next seven
to ten days and will he please finally
declare a national critical incident so
we can mobilize every single bit of our
NHS to save lives and save the NHS
the very purpose of the announcement
today and I've done it on the first day
that Parliament is back is to give that
urgent uh uplifting funding to local
authorities to icbs to act now knowing
that that funding is available they have
the additional 500 million which is
ramping up as well and that is part of a
wider package of measures as I say NHS
England put in the community bed
supporting the 7000 but the purpose is
to recognize the very real immediate
pressure the front line has been in but
that also needs to be viewed as
something that other Healthcare Systems
across the globe have also faced from
what has been a very sudden and very
significant spike in flu seven times
higher than last month and a hundred
times what it was last year so rapidly
yes but they also have covid and flu in
France or Germany or Italy or Sweden or
Holland and winter after winter they
coped far better because have much more
integrated social insurance systems now
some people like me be banging on this
for years but now the former Health
secretary the member of Bronze Grove is
suggesting a social insurance system
newspaper editorial after newspaper
editorial what is our long-term plan we
can't leave the labor party to have a
long-term plan and we don't how are we
going to how are we going to reform this
centrally controlled construct so the
people of my age pay taxes all their
life and the only right is to join the
back of a two-year queue what is his
plan
Secretary of State well firstly
integrating between Health and Social
care through the integrated care boards
that is what we put in place from July
recognizing that actually the pressures
on the NHS are often as much about
pressuring social care as they are in
NHS uh itself particularly if you look
at ambulances often it is actually they
delay in domiciliary care that is
driving there that blockage on the wards
which in turn applies there secondly it
is recognizing that the Royal Workforce
pressures and that is why anxious
England have been working on the
workforce plan which have been set up
and thirdly we have already set out our
electives recovery plan you saw wrote Mr
Speaker Mr W speaker will have seen over
the summer that those longest weights of
over two years were largely cleared and
from the fund bench they turn to as to
how it's going well if you look at how
that is going compared to the labor
government's two-year clearance in Wales
where there's over 60 000 or around
sixty thousand Before Christmas in Wales
waiting over two years in England that
was under uh two thousand so we are
making progress on those longest weights
through the work of Jim Mackey and
Professor Tim Riggs and the get it
rights first time we are innovating with
the surgical herbs the community
diagnostic Centers that in turn gives
greater resilience to those electives
that in the past used to be canceled
when there was winter pressure that then
go on hot and cold sites where they're
then much more resilient but the final
issue I must take with what he said is
actually in France in Germany in Canada
in many other countries this massive
spike in flu and covid uh pressure
combined with the pressures from the
pandemic has placed similar strains on
other Healthcare Systems so it is simply
not the case to say that this is an
issue that affects England and England
alone in Diana Johnson
despite all the warnings I'm really not
clear how the government has got itself
into this position of the biggest crisis
in the NHS we all know it's a no-brainer
you have to invest in Social care to
reduce bed flocking so what exactly is
the purpose of the pilot that's been
announced for Holland the Humber that
will tell us what we already know that
what we need is investment in Social
care and reform of social care
well firstly we recognized uh very early
in fact uh in the summer NHS England
recognized that this winter was likely
to be extremely hard both because uh
population resilience to flu would be
lower as a consequence of the pandemic
and because of the combination of the
panic pandemic backlogs and the ongoing
level of covid emissions over 9000 cases
in hospital we covered then a further as
I say 5000 from flu on top of the other
strains from the pandemic that we have
seen But the measures that were being
taken such as boosting the vaccination
program extending that to the over 50s
being the first place to have the
bivalent vaccine to address those were
part of the package on measures that
nhsc will have put in its operational
plan but we also reckoned to the heart
of our question that social care is
Central to this and that is why in the
Autumn statement notwithstanding the
other economic pressures that the
government faced health and education
were prioritized with the extra 6.6
billion of funding into the NHS over the
next two years and an extra 7.5 billion
pounds of funding into social care so it
was recognized that was a clear
prioritization in the Autumn statement
the reality is we've had a massive spike
in flu cases which means we have a
hundred times the number of Hospital
emissions from flu compared to last year
Holly Amanda Croft hey Mr Deputy speaker
um can I firstly welcome the measures
that my actual friend has set out for us
today and it's absolutely right that we
consider a wide Suite of measures with
that in mind can I draw his attention to
my own region we have I think the second
biggest ICB area by geography but
without the population numbers to match
that so can I ask him to consider an
additional Community diagnostic Hub so
that everyone in the area is able to to
access that we need one sorry we need
two not one so we'll look at that please
yeah I think Chris said well I think my
honorable friend is absolutely right to
highlight the importance of dynastic
centers and that is why that is one of
the things that we have uh in particular
prioritize as she knows I'm extremely
Keen that we accelerate that program so
that where we award Community diagnostic
Centers that they are opening in 2023 in
my view to many of the plans were for
2024 so that is a particular challenge
that I have been posing uh but I know
this is something she has campaigned
strongly for on behalf of our
constituents and in the minister of
state is very much looking at the
proposal Chief has shared and I know he
will be happy to discuss it with her in
the days ahead Maria thank you thank you
Mr Deputy speaker hospitals used by my
constituents in Liverpool and nosley
have had cues at a e of 33 hours 41
hours 30 plus hours have had dozens of
ambulances queuing up outside for entire
shifts unable to transfer even one
patient in an entire shift these
problems were predictable and as he's
just said predicted yet the Secretary of
State disappeared over Christmas and the
new year when this was going on only
emerged last week to blame the problems
on flu and covin when is he going to
acknowledge that leaving it until
January to deal with an issue of winter
pressure says too little too late when
is he going to take responsibility and
apologize for the lamentable situation
that he's left my constituents and many
others across this country in fear pain
worry when is he going to say sorry for
it
well Mr W is simply not accurate for
example let me give her some specifics
the auxiliary contract with St John's
ambulance that we invested in we put an
extra 150 million into the ambulance
service we invested additional capacity
into call centers for further 50 million
um but also it is important to note we
the taxpayers spend 800 million pounds
on the new Royal Liverpool Hospital in
2018-19 Aintree brand new uh hospital
was built there so we have been
investing in there but it's also about
recognizing that it's not simply about
investing in new hospitals it's also
about looking at the integration between
Health and Care and that is what the
Autumn statement recognized with the
additional 500 million pounds but it's
simply inaccurate to say that there
weren't measures in the summer such as
the Saint John's ambulance contract the
Community First Responders the frail
elderly service that has been put in
place these are all measures to to help
with demand management to prevent people
coming to the emergency Department in
the first place sir Julian Lewis
does the government recognize that there
is a danger of a major increase in
pressure on the NHS resulting from any
new variant of covid that may be
imported from China and how quickly
would be we be able to identify such a
new variant and prepare a vaccine
against it so just thank you well first
Mr W sub speaker may I and I'm sure the
whole house congratulates my uh I'm a
friend on these uh his Knighthood from
his his majesty in terms of of China the
the analysis we have is that the the
variants in China is the same as the
variants in the UK
um but on the other hand the data that
has been shared from China is often not
as clear as we would like that is why
the Prime Minister and uh the minister
for Trans the minority friend the
minister for transport announced uh the
proportionate measures over Christmas in
term terms of looking at
positive tests for travelers but in
particular sequence varying testing for
those coming into the UK the purpose of
that is to quickly identify any new
variant in order to respond to the the
concerning highlights there's several
roles
strikes
[Music]
by patient safety is suffering due to
increased Demand on staff shortages now
instead of proper pay increases labor
Welsh government have responded by
offering Welsh Health Service staff
tokenistic one-off payments and
reportedly his government is considering
the same in England as well now if this
approach is taken can the minister
guarantee that one-off payments we
recognize as support with cost of living
crisis rather than proper pay increases
and treated as such for tax and benefit
purposes
second state well personally as we have
said previously Mr WWE process through
the independent Behavior view body that
looks at these issues in the round and
balances what are the needs uh in terms
of our NHS obviously my focus is on the
NHS in the England uh more than uh the
it's for the world's coming in terms of
the negotiation uh in Wales and
balancing what is uh the right level of
funding for retention and recruitment
against what are the wider issues of
affordability for the economy as a whole
but we are very keen to engage with the
trainees we had a good discussion uh
with them uh today I'm pleased that they
recognize that made progress and I look
forward to having further discussions
with them
Siobhan Bailey thank you Mr Deputy
speaker I've had a few
um steriled constituents in tears in
recent weeks as they've been with loved
ones in a e and elderly residents um
stuck on on trolleys
um no MP wants to deal with that and I
know you're working hard and I welcome
the announcements but the public are
watching more and more money go into the
NHS and what I think we need to hear
very clearly is what is your assessment
what is my own friends assessment of
when the new announcements the more
money is going to make meaningful change
in gloucestershire's a e departments and
elsewhere
well I think it's a very fair Challenge
and I I would segment it into three
sections I think firstly there is a
recognition that the combination of the
the Legacy from the pandemic the uh
ongoing covered pressure but
particularly this massive spike in flu
creates an immediate pressure in our a e
and the package today recognizes that it
shows we have listened to the front line
and and responded to that but the
secondly there is a recognition uh and
it goes to some of the questions in the
house today that the system has been
under pressure for some time and
therefore the second phase is around
looking at innovation technology the AI
the virtual Wards the ways of doing
things differently that actually
particularly if I take the frail elderly
addresses their needs Upstream in the
care home before they get to the
emergency department or that releases
them from hospital quicker providing
they have the safety net that they're
part of a virtual War where they're
subject to ongoing clinical supervision
and if they need to come back to
hospital they can do so much more easily
than would otherwise be the case and
stopping that that Boomerang of patients
released early and then coming back
that's the second phase and that
includes for example the modular
capacity as well because to streamline
to triage they need space and it is that
compression within the emergency
department that also drives inefficiency
and poor care but there's also a third
part and this government has invested in
its life science Industry our rmd
investment of 15 to 20 billion pounds is
a big Mark of that and part of the
prioritize is to say actually there are
certain things we can do at scale with
companies like moderna which will shift
the down in terms of health care and
that is a third but significant part and
particularly around the prevention work
that we can do
I was not only having an impact on the
acute service but on the Mental Health
Service as well I have raised directly
with the Secretary of State the problems
facing whole and a Humber NHS trust
where we have um learning adult learning
difficulty beds 42 of those have been
taken by patients with delayed discharge
the adult mental health bed 17 have been
taken by patients who are waiting for
discharge and in children and Adolescent
mental health beds 22 of those are with
patients waiting for a discharge from
these hospital and mental health beds so
what investment and support is going to
be given to providing the right social
care and support services to enable not
just feds to be freed up in the acute
service but friends to be freed up
they're desperately needed in Mental
Health Services as well
The Honorable lady's right to highlight
mental health it is an extremely uh
important part of this wider Health
landscape that's why the government's
increasing funding to mental health the
extra 2.3 billion that is going in but
it's also about how we get better value
for money from that spending as well and
that is why through the reform of the
mental health act that my honorable
friend the minister of mental health is
taking forward that will also help us
better Target that funding in ways that
delivers value for money
Richard Graham
I joined the Health and Care secretary
in paying tribute to those working in
hospitals like the lost jewel Hospital
in my constituency so intensely and
under such heavy pressure and while I
welcome the changes he's announced can
the health secretary confirm what
progress his department has made with
the home office to prioritize tier 2
Health visas and also to provide a grace
period for international GP trainees
lastly could I write on a friend
consider helping staff with parking and
out of ours food in this winter
described by so many as a perfect storm
secret well Mr Debbie's week as I I said
in my uh remarks at the outset the
announcement today is part of the wider
recovery program which we discuss with
health leaders at number 10 on Saturday
that will have a number of components
one of which is around the Urgent and
emergency care recovery work is ongoing
with home office colleagues in terms of
the Visa component of that he raises a
extremely important point one that a
number of clinicians on the front line
have also raised with me and it's
something that I'm discussing with my my
tomorrow friend the Home Secretary
Stephanie peacock
[Music]
yeah what is the government doing to
reassure people those in Barnsley who
are waiting in pay for delayed
operations and will they make sure that
any new staff are deployed first to the
areas that need it most
well I share her desire for us to reduce
the backlog on the Alexis program that
is why the government's invested a uh
for the 8 billion pounds but in order to
ensure that that delivers value for
money the key Focus now is building
Greater resilience into that elective
program through the surgical hubs
through the better use of community
diagnostic Centers and particular by
having a a distinction between the hot
and cold sites what too often has
happened in the past is as winter
pressures have surged so elective
operations are canceled in order to free
up bed capacity and by having the
surgical herbs having the hot and cold
sites that builds greater resilience and
that is if I can pay tribute to to the
work of the get it right first time team
and Professor Tim Briggs and Jim Mackey
that is exactly the program they're
leading you saw the progress that was
made in the summer on that we're very
focused on the next stage which is 78
week weight and we're working very
actively on that
Jason McCartney uh thank you Mr Deputy
speaker Maple Ward at home Valley
Memorial Hospital used to provide much
needed Community Intermediate Care for
those leaving Huddersfield Royal
infirmary unfortunately it temporarily
closed I think around uh six years ago
does the Secretary of State agree with
me that this is exactly the kind of
facility that we need now in the
community to not only give great
Intermediate Care but also to free up
capacity of our main hospitals
he was an extremely important point
because whilst often the debate is on
beds it is is in reality as much about
the workforce that goes with those beds
that we need to consider and the point
about step down care is that it has a
lighter patient staff ratio compared to
what is necessary for uh much more
serious patients at the acute stage so
it is important that we look at the
end-to-end capacity that includes step
down care that's why NHS England in
their summer plans set out the 7 000
additional beds but that in turn also
includes doing things differently using
technology and the virtual Awards allow
some patients to be at home which many
patients prefer but with the wrap around
clinical support that virtual Awards can
provide so virtual water part of that so
are as he says step down in the
community and that is part of that wider
landscape so foreign
for an ambulance calling 999 three times
pleading for health they waited for
three hours but by the time an ambulance
arrived it was too late paramedics
desperately tried to save his life but
the 58 year old father tragically passed
away his daughter Minnie was clear about
who was to blame it was an NHS stuff she
said but Tory governments who have left
the NHS in what she called a disastrous
state so what was the health secretary
heed Mini's words and anju 13 years of
running down our NHS from giving NHS
workers a proper pay rise to ending all
forms of privatization and giving the
NHS the funding it desperately needs the
Tuesday
as I said in my opinion were up so I
regret the fact that there are some
patients and staff in the emergency care
that did not receive acceptable care in
recent weeks but I I just gently remind
lady that that pressure particularly
around flu and covered rates is
something that has put huge pressure on
the NHS in Wales in Scotland across
Europe and indeed across the globe
Andrew Jones
Mr Speaker can I thank my right humble
friend for this statement and Welcome
North yorkshire's involvement in the
trials he's announced today he
highlighted The increased bed occupancy
that's come from the flu surge well NHS
North Yorkshire briefed me earlier this
afternoon that the flu vaccination take
up in North Yorkshire was 64.
at 64 now that basically means that one
in three people are not vaccinated
so does he agree with me that more
focused on encouraging vaccination take
up is a way that we can all help uh in
alleviating this crisis and reducing
demand upon hospitals
secretary Mr w i i very much agree with
my uh honorable friend in encouraging
greater uh vaccine uh Taker and that is
something I think across the house we
can agree is something to be encouraged
and I hope all members will be
reinforcing uh the UK hsa's uh messages
on the take-up on vaccine we've expanded
the scope to include the over 50s we had
a world-leading vaccine in the
benevolent vaccine which targets both
Omicron and the original strain of flu
but it's also important that as many
people as possible get their flu jab as
well and I encourage all members to
support that Caroline Lucas thank thank
you sir Roger the NHS and social care
are in unprecedented crisis even if
that's a word that both he and the Prime
Minister refuse to use we know that
resilience was stripped out of our NHS
years before the covid pandemic and I
come back to the level of vacancies 133
000 tonight NHS 165 000 in Social care
so will the minister admit that as well
as growing the workforce we urgently
need to keep the workforce that we have
and if so why isn't the government at
least meeting the nurses halfway on pay
as the RCN have offered and why after 13
years of Tory government is the average
care worker pay less than pay at
McDonald's or Amazon
Secretary of State well Mr goodbye
within that list it would have been uh
welcome had you recognized the
significant investment the government's
made in Brighton in a new hospital as
part of the additional funding that
we're making there's also more doctors
more nurses within the NHS this year
than there were last year but to her
point on social care a part of the
purpose of the 500 million that the
chancellor announced in the Autumn
statement was to recognize the pressure
on Workforce that is why that funding
was prioritized that is also why home
office colleagues have put social care
workers on the shortage occupation list
to better enables us to also attract
International Talent Robin Walker
I've made many sensible points in his
statement but he'll forgive me if I
focus on the local aspect of things in
Worcestershire whereas you know these
pressures have remained very acute our
two a E's over December saw 14 000
attendances that's up from 12 500 of the
year before and 10 600 the year before
that and the hospital trust tell me that
on any given day in December they had
around 100 patients who could be cared
for somewhere else in hospital beds
given that I read one of his press
releases today announced extra funding
for neighboring Warwickshire can I urge
him to ensure that out of this 200
million funding package a significant
amount reaches those was sheer hospitals
and to remember the acute need to
upgrade at INE something I understand is
due to happen during the course of this
year
uh Wilmington Road there are plans to
upgrade the a e as he knows I think when
I was Chief secretary I signed off those
plans but they have been delayed because
of some contractual disputes on the
ground and I share his desire to see
those expedited because the government
has made that investment and therefore
we want to see the operational
performance that comes from it but is
also right in terms of the announcement
today will enable
icbs including within his area to
accelerate their discharge plans there
were already plans in place because of
the funding from the Autumn statement
what today's announcement does is allow
them to go further and quicker in
releasing those patients because that in
turn takes pressure on the the a e
Department
yeah thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's
one thing to talk about block cooking
beds but care is about stuff too as many
members on this side of race how does he
expect Care Homes to cope with this
increased pressure one in 10 social care
posts remain empty and Staff feel
overworked underpaid and exhausted and
last year report commissioned by the
health services department reported the
rapid discharge of people from hospitals
to Care Homes during the first wave of
the pandemic without adequate covered
testing was highly likely to have caused
some outbreaks how will the health
secretary avoid the Fatal mistakes of
the past mitigate against the seating of
more infections to Care Homes and the
danger as my honorable friend on the
front bench said that unsuitable care
may lead to readmissions to hospital
anyway secretary of state will to her
point it is a very uh good one in terms
of is there a risk of repeating some of
the issues from the past in terms of
infections into Care Homes and I think
it's worth a house reflecting on the
fact we're in a very different position
uh to at the start of the pandemic
firstly we have the vaccine which we
didn't have in place for care home
residents and staff secondly we have
antivirals that we didn't have in place
and thirdly there's huge amount of
knowledge in terms of covid that wasn't
the case at the start of the pandemic so
in terms of releasing people into care
homes that risking from an infection
point of view is in a very different
place to where we were before on The
Wider issues of Workforce part of the
reason for the 500 million at the Autumn
statement was to put in place support
measures for Workforce but it is also
why through our International
recruitment we're also looking
internationally to boost numbers so
Robert sent
can I welcome what the secretary of
state has said about Community
pharmacies they've always wanted to do
more and I think because of the pressure
on GPS they could take a lot of the
burden off and if access to GPS has
improved then fewer people will turn up
in a e it seems to be a win-win-win
situation let's go and do this yeah oh
yeah I couldn't agree more Mr W speaker
with my right on my friend I think
there's huge opportunities to do more
through Pharmacists and that is
something that I've asked the department
in NHS England to explore at PACE and I
expect to say more on that through our
recovery plans at the end of the month
but if I may I think we can go even
further because alongside pharmacists I
think there is much more scope to work
with employers there's significant cost
to employers particularly if I take
cardiovascular conditions when staff are
absent so it is in employers interest to
work with us in terms of some of the
prevention measures and also there's
much more that can be done through home
testing one of the lessons from covid is
the that actually the public will do
tests at home and I think in terms of
when one let's particulate The Challenge
on excess deaths there's significant
opportunities to do more home testing
employer testing and work in the
community and in particular with
Pharmacy there are harp house thank you
sir Roger one of my constituents fell
seriously ill recently his wife rang 999
it was a category 2 emergency then
escalated to category one but it still
took the ambulance nearly two hours to
arrive and despite the paramedics heroic
efforts my constituent sadly died there
are now up to 500 avoidable deaths per
week due to a e delays according to the
Royal College of emergency medicine will
the government support the ambulance
waiting times Bill introduced by my
friend
the member for Saint Albans to
identifying hot spots over the largest
waiting times and put support where it
is most urgently needed secretary
will Mr Deputy speaker I've seen a lot
in in the media in terms of speculation
around the the excess mortality to which
she refers and it is an issue that I've
discussed in detail with both the the
chief medical officer and also the
medical director for NHS England and the
point to note is this is something
firstly that's happened internationally
it can't be ascribed just to warn uh
issue as is so often uh the case some of
the excess mortality will be due
directly to covid itself albeit that
will be a dimensionally diminishing uh
proportion but it is also the case that
some of the non-covered excess mortality
will be driven by quite a wide
combination of factors so I think we've
got to be quite cautious when those sort
of numbers are banded around Amanda
Milling
speaker I've recently had very alarming
reports from constituents of mine who've
had to wait for over 20 hours for an
ambulance so can my right honorable
friend set out and further detail how
they measures outline today will also
support ambulances to reach patients
quicker
so the the measures in our state speak
to the heart that of that issue which is
by putting in more capacity to
decompress emergency departments what
that does is in particular it allows
more same-day emergency care where
patients can be rapidly assessed
diagnosed and treated without being
admitted to a ward will also buy
unblocking capacity on Wards it means
that emergency departments can release
patients which in turn creates a
capacity for ambulances to hand over
patients what causes the delay in Hammer
handovers from ambulances is where the
emergency department is already at
capacity and therefore there is an
understandable reluctance from
clinicians for additional patients to
come in so it's about freeing up the
capacity within the emergency department
but it that is both a front door issue
in terms of the operation of same-day
Emergency Care it is also about what's
happening at the back door of the
hospital in terms of the labor discharge
thank you Mr deficit speaker the
secretary States is that the government
will now block book residential homes
for Hospital discharges but social care
is in crisis and has been for many many
years and care workers are leaving the
profession in droves due to low pay and
poor conditions so what will the
secretary of state do to recognize the
incredibly highly skilled work or care
workers do and pay them what is it they
deserve to prevent them from leaving to
go to supermarkets or Amazon because
quite frankly the international
recruitment Drive is meaningless unless
we retain existing staff
secretary say well I'd say Mr w we need
to do both we we need to maximize the
international recruitment but we also
need to retain uh existing staff and
that is why the chancellor in the Autumn
statement prioritized with all the other
competing pressures that he faced he
prioritize 7.5 billion pounds into
social care over the next two years
that's the biggest ever increase uh
under any government so it was
recognizing the centrality of social
care in terms of The Wider pressures on
the NHS and of course that's 1.5 billion
came alongside a further 6.6 billion
that was announced at the Autumn
statement to invest in the NHS over the
next two years Mark Posey thank you Mr
Deputy speaker does the Secretary of
State agree that many of those who are
going to need to be admitted to hospital
during coming weeks will have reason to
welcome the fact that this government
unlike the party opposite doesn't have a
prejudice against making use of
facilities from within the independent
sector
uh well I I agree I think it's important
that we uh maximize uh capacity uh in
the independent sector that is what uh
we are committed to doing I very much
agree with him
Jonathan Edwards
Edwards that's a Roger uh
receives correspondence from consultant
space to make situents complaining about
the tax liabilities they face as a
result of their picture contributions
which forces them to reduce their own
words or leave uh Public Health
altogether I understand that the
government are Consulting authorship and
it's probably a matter for the treasury
but uh how close does he believe we are
to an Innovative solution
well The Honorable judgment I think
raising the point that uh is raised with
him as you can imagine it is also raised
with me by many senior clinicians uh he
is right that it is a question for the
chancellor I'm very happy to share the
point that he he raised but as he knows
taxes are a matter for the treasury and
I know my voter my friend is considering
this Jack Rarity thank you Mr deaf
speaker as the secretary of state knows
there are serious pressures within the
NHS in North Staffordshire and the chief
executive of the royal Stoke said on
radio Stoke uh last week that the key
issue to addressing these pressures is
dealing with social care so will my
rightful friend give me the assurances
that these measures today will deliver
more social care places across North
Staffordshire so interesting well I'm
very happy firstly to give that
Assurance to my almond oil friend but
also I think it's important to see the
announcements today in the context of
the announcements of the Autumn
statement and the further announcements
made earlier by the government around
integrating Health and Social care
through the integrated care board and
those together will not only provide
additional funding it will improve
significantly the data which will
address also some of the interface
challenges that we have when patients
are being who are medical fit to be
discharged from hospital so we can
better Ensure the different Pathways
whether it's Thomas Hillary care
Intermediate Care or Residential Care
the pathways one two three are operating
in a better way
the period my constituents took their
two-year-old child to the a e hospital
because of their severe breathing
difficulties it soon became apparent
that they needed to be hospitalized and
no beds were made available some 34
hours later spent in a e a bed was then
found I'm sure honorable members and
honorable friends from across this house
can imagine some how scary and how
exhausting this experience was for the
whole family does the minister view this
experience as acceptable and is this the
new Norm that the public should now
expect for our National Health Service
under a conservative government yeah
foreign
I recognized that the the start of my
statement but in terms of the The Wider
Point around where specific very
troubling cases like that come to life
one of the purposes behind the
integrated care boards having
integrative Care Systems having control
centers is so we actually get much
earlier side of issues much clearer
escalation and so these sort of issues
then get much more scrutiny than is
currently the case Rob Butler thank you
very much Mr Deputy speaker in addition
to the substantial increase in the
number of cases the flu that my right
honorable friend mentioned uh the
intense cold snap shortly before
Christmas put further unforeseeable
pressure on hospitals Stoke Mandeville
Hospital my own constituency saw four
times as many broken hips as it normally
would in that period so I paid tribute
to all the staff at bucks NHS trust for
treating those additional patients and I
warmly welcome the health structures
announcement to free up thousands of
beds does he agree with me that key to
that is putting a real great focus on
Intermediate Care and intermediate step
down beds and that it'll therefore be
very important for integrated care
boards including the one covering
buckinghamshire to put an intense
concentration on that and on working
constructively and effectively with the
local Authority in the local NHS trust
so so I think he raises an important
point and I think that is the the role
of step down care in releasing uh
capacity from hospital or Freedom
capacity in hospital but I think it is
extremely important and it was a point I
was Keen to emphasize in my opening
remarks that where patients are
discharged from hospital we have the
right wrap around support and care for
those patients it's not simply a
question in the next few weeks of
discharging those patients there needs
to be the wrap around care as well he's
also right to point to the fact that
there have been a number of uh very
significant increases in demand the
four-fold increase that he highlights
that combined with flu come out with
Kobe combined with the pandemic Legacy
meant there were very significant
pressures and that demand pressure
combined if I take flu with an impact on
Supply because it also exacerbates stuff
absences during what was the Christmas
period my apologies to the Secretary of
State play that's it
it's enthusiastic to make the
contribution as you were for me to do
um so what what uh what contingency did
the Secretary of State put in place for
a spike in flu cases because he speaks
as if it's taken the department by
surprise but it was widely predicted
that there would be a a spike in flu
cases following on from the lockdowns
during during covid and he's announced 4
500 places for easing pressure today but
in his own statement he said in 2020
there were just 6 000 cases of delayed
discharged just six thousand as if it's
not significant and whereas it last year
it was between 12 and 13 000 cases per
day so he's announced what's roughly a
third of what's he said it was roughly
the average per day for the last year
isn't this just too little too late
firstly the the central
um announcement of the Autumn statement
was the additional capacity to deal with
domiciliary care and and further support
for social care that's where the 500
million announcement and that was part
of the 2.8 billion next year 4.7 billion
uh the year after so the Autumn
statement recognized the fact indeed the
chancellor uh I'd have to go back and
check his transcript but certainly there
were many comments around that period
pointing to the fact that this was
likely to be the worst ever winter
because of both the combination of
pandemic pressure uh cavid emissions but
also the risk of flu which has
transpired to be the worst for 10 years
but in terms of what additional capacity
that is why for example we expanded uh
the cohort that was eligible for the flu
and covid vaccine and it's funded that
to the over 50s and invested in the
Bible and vaccine it's y NHS England
place an additional seven thousand uh
beds it's why we have been rolling out
the virtual Awards of the sort that what
for General is able to address the
equivalent of an extra Ward so
additional measures have been put in
place what we saw over that Christmas
period uh in line with what happened in
Wales what happened in Scotland what
happened internationally was a very
rapid Spike seven times the increasing
flu over a very short period of time and
that came on top of the pressures that
were already in the system
roof heads
I've got the sexual estate statement and
the new funding announced in
Nottinghamshire the Nottingham
University Hospital trust had to declare
a critical incident between the 29th of
December and the 6th of January they
need this new funding to help discharge
more patients now so can the Secretary
of State confirm when the money will
arrive and start making a difference to
my constituents in Nottinghamshire but
also what his department is doing not
only to attract new people to work in
Social care but also to try and win back
some of those who have recently left
to address her two points firstly the
NHS will take immediate actions to start
of Aging additional step-down care so
that is a very clear message that she
could take to her constituents in terms
of the fact that ligament has listened
and acted on the very real pressures
that we have seen in terms of The Wider
social care
um if I take she's not in a place now
but an example with the gene Bishop
integrated Care Center actually by
co-locating social care stuff and NHS
staff one of the things that the
feedback I receive from those staff was
that integrated model is actually
extremely rewarding for staff it's a
much better way of operating than
working in in silos and so that
co-location that greater integration
between social care and health is
actually something the workforce
themselves have said is extremely
beneficial Tim Farrah thank you sir
Roger
patients living with cancer and their
families and the outstanding cancer
Workforce will be staggered as am I that
we just had a statement on NHS pressures
with no serious plan being put forward
for tackling the deadly cancer backlow
17 000 cancer patients in the last three
months had their targets for cancer
treatment delayed and missed 43 of
people diagnosed with cancer in South
Cumbria waited more than two months for
their first life-saving treatment in
North Cumbria 63 percent of of those
people diagnosed with cancer waited more
than two months for their first
treatment so where is the Urgent plan to
tackle the cancer backlog and on a very
practical cross-party level will he
attend or one of his ministers attend
the all-party Parliamentary group on
radiotherapy's inquiry on the 18th of
January so we can work together to come
with some quick Technical Solutions that
will actually save lives secretary say
so firstly it's worth um just pointing
out to the house at 92 92 percent of the
new patients so starting their cancer
treatment within uh four weeks but also
so here's the substance of his point
that is exactly why we're rolling out
the program of community diagnostic
Centers it's why we've got the surgical
hubs program in order to prioritize
those cancer treatments and also given
that it was a central part of the
statement today it is rather surprising
that the major investment at bringing
the potential of cancer will leading
cancer vaccines from our life science
strategy which could be absolutely
transformational for cancer patients
wasn't even referenced there and it's
something I hope he does support because
it has the potential to be game changing
Andrew Percy thank you uh sir Roger um
the secretary says absolutely right
there is nothing unique to the UK about
this precisely because there have been
record delays at Canadian hospitals
Canadian ARS have been closed through
staff shortages and some Canadian cities
have had no ambulance cover at certain
times they have expanded the role of
paramedics to enable them to do more
Diagnostics and also to do prescribing
and there's somebody who works in that
service can I just say it's not just
about the delays at getting into
hospitals the demand on the ambulance
service is driven equally by the fact we
have more people living for longer with
more conditions which sometimes require
Care at one or two in the morning and
the only service that will turn out from
the NHS is the ambulance service so can
I ask you what his vision is for the
future of community pyramids and how we
can expand paramedic roles employ more
advanced paramedics and of course put
the proper resources into that service
well he he raises a brilliant point and
one I completely agree with about how we
upskill the existing Workforce how we
get more uh people operating at uh
what's referred to as the top of their
license uh we as part of the discussions
we had uh on Saturday number 10 one of
the key areas was looking at how we
better utilize the existing Workforce
and their roles and what regulatory
changes we need to maximize that uh can
I pay tribute to the work he I know did
over the Christmas period as a community
first responder and he's absolutely
right looking at how for example we
better integrate the data that's
available to paramedics and therefore
enable them to do more that is exactly
the direction of travel that we want to
take and I look forward to discussing
that further with them carry my coffee
last month I asked the Prime Minister
about a constituent with dementia who
waited three hours for an ambulance and
then spent 10 hours in the back of that
ambulance in the car park at a e and
we've heard much worse examples today
I've now been contacted by another
constituent who went into cardiac arrest
in his GP surgery waited two hours for
an ambulance and eventually the GP ended
up driving him to hospital himself and
probably saved his life
can the Secretary of State give us some
confidence that all that he's talking
about today is going to filter through
quickly in terms of ambulance response
times because at the moment my
constituents are terrified that if they
call for an ambulance it won't come
that's right Secretary of State and it
is when one looks at the media coverage
a very fair challenge that The Honorable
lady raises and and just to give her a
sense of what underscores our approach
15 trusts are responsible for 56 of
ambulance Handover delays so the
targeting of additional capacity
particularly I want to think of how we
we target that announcement today into
those areas where that is most acute is
obviously one of the the central things
that we're doing at pace so there's a
very significant concentration of that
there's also opportunities where we look
at this the variation in performance to
look at what is working effectively in
other trusts and that combination of
control centers better Upstream demand
management is absolutely core all to
particularly cohorts such as dementia
patients so the significant
opportunities to Bear the target the
interventions and actually singling can
be doing a lot of work on that uh as
part of their 100-day Sprint uh exercise
but there's more we can do in the
funding today speech center Jonathan
guys
very much Mr Deputy speaker I want to
first of all put on record my thanks to
the incredible staff both at the Royal
State University Hospital and the
Haywood walking Center have been facing
unprecedented pressures and Tracy
Bullock and Neil Carter serve their full
respect Mr Speaker there's two problems
we have in staff sure one is that
Community First Responders do not have
the blue light ability that was taken
away by westminers ambulance service
when will that be reinstated and the
secret is the community pharmacist can
indeed do more I'm delighted that we are
going to see them do more but their core
funding does need to increase and hasn't
since 2014 so how will that be rectified
well on the blue lightsability I'm very
happy to take that away uh and look at
that as is often the case these things
are slightly more nuanced as I
discovered when we're looking at mod uh
ambulance drivers and and their
interaction with blue lights but I'm
very happy to look at that in terms of
the Community Pharmacy uh that is
something my honorable friend is looking
at particularly uh in terms of how we
better enable patients to get the right
treatment in the right place and given
the fact that Community Pharmacy is very
accessible uh actually you get higher
numbers in in sometimes more deprived
communities there's significant
opportunities for us to do more with
them and I know it's something that the
ministerial team is working on it
doesn't matter thank you Mr Deputy
speaker I listened with something crude
to Unity to the Secretary of State's
explanation because the ICB is only six
months old they're still getting to
grips with the link between Health and
Social care who does he think was
running Health and Social care before
the icbs were created it was the very
same people they know exactly what the
issues are what they are lacking is a
government committee to dealing with the
systemic issues facing both sectors one
of those issues as we've heard already
is Workforce and social care a quick
internet search before revealed there
are 200 social care vacancies within a
10-mile radius of Ellesmere port and we
know as we've heard already there are
165 000 social care vacancies Nationwide
I haven't heard anything from the
Secretary of State today about what he's
actually going to do that will address
those vacancies so can you tell us in a
year's time how many social care
vacancies across the country does he
expect there to be so just say well in
terms of the interaction with vacancies
and Workforce NHS England has already
been addressed in the course of the
debate is working on a Workforce
strategy for the NHS and we'll say more
on that shortly but to his wider point I
think what he's ignoring there is uh
examples like the gene Bishop integrated
Care Center the ability to bring Health
sector staff and social Care staff to
work together in a more integrated way
yes the integrated care boards were
operational form July and that's a
factual statement that's when they
became operational so I'm slightly
mystified as to why he think that's in
in some way uh an unusual observation to
make that is just the factual position
but the point is when uh one looks at
that there are opportunities
particularly around how the data is
better integrated to understand where
the workflow pressures are where the bed
capacity is and one of the the causes of
uh delayed discharge is actually around
the interfaces as well as what is uh
domiciliary care what is step down and
what are these residentials so there's a
number of issues in the integrated care
board by bringing that together in a
more integrated way will be one of the
ways we improve that and indeed that is
what his former colleague Patricia
shewitt through the shuitt review is
looking at peterbone uh thank you Mr
Deputy speaker and I'm grateful for the
Secretary of State to get into grip with
delayed discharges but as he will know
only a third of delayed discharges are
due to social care most of Doubt down to
the fact that there needs to be NSF NHS
medical discharges now I've got some
good news for him Mr definitely speaker
the bad news is that spinny fields in my
constituency a 51 bed social care step
down facility is going to be closed
but Mr Deputy speaker if the Secretary
of State
spends a small portion of that 250
million pounds
the NHS could take over smithfields and
tomorrow 51 beds will be released at the
acute hospitals in Northampton and
Kettering could he agree to it now
well one of the things I think my uh
honorable friend actually agrees with is
as devolving more decisions and not
trying to run uh every decision uh from
Westminster and part of the reason
behind the integrated care boards is so
that they can look at where best to
allocate their funds locally so I think
the point he raises is an extremely
important one is right that around a
quarter of delayed discharges uh on the
uh the social care side of fifth
actually the NHS there's a number of
factors within it so we'll need to
disaggregate it but two he is his point
uh enters walk capacity is there locally
the government is allocating that
funding to his local ICB and I'm sure he
will have uh that conversation with his
ICB in terms of where the spare capacity
can be best identified and rolled out at
PACE Toby Perkins thank you very much
sir Roger I met last week with Hal
Spencer the chief executive of
Chesterfield Royal Hospital on the
pressures that he and his staff had
faced his Chesterfield went into a
critical incident over Christmas were
etched all over his face he spoke about
uh the pressures on a e registrars on
ambulance drivers and nurses of coming
up face to face with people who've been
waiting 24 hours in a corridor on a
trolley all people have been waiting
many hours for an ambulance to turn up
isn't the reality that this is a
system-wide failure 13 years in the
making and didn't The Honorable
gentleman from Gainsborough hit his nail
on the head when he said that labor have
a long-term plan for NHS and this
government don't
secretary of state so so the first point
that you know is this a system-wide
challenge absolutely it's a system-wide
challenge and that is why what happens
in terms of demand management
um Upstream in the care home in the home
how we're using Innovation such as
virtual Wards in that capacity is
important just as uh discharge and
getting those patients that are fit to
leave hospital is equally important and
so whilst often the focus has been on
ambulances being delayed at a e or the
very significant and real pressures
within emergency departments themselves
actually the challenges are much wider
one and that is what the funding at the
Autumn statement recognized but to his
second point which is this is about a
longer term issue within England
specifically I would just point him to
the examples in Wales I'll put him to
the pressures in Scotland and also the
fact that this surge in flu combined
with covid and pandemic Legacy that we
have seen in England's create so much
pressure over the festive period is
something many other Health Systems
around the globe have also been
grappling with and of course
this extra funding and I look forward to
hearing how much will be coming to South
End Hospital who have had to deal with
not one but two critical incidents
declared by the east of England
Ambulance Service they have already
innovated with modular units and an
active discharge Lounge these NHS
workers deserve all of our recognition
and what they need is the capital
funding the 8 million of capital funding
to reconfigure the hospital which is
fundamentally not big enough in the
short term would you would he agree to
encourage Care Homes to take discharges
after 5 PM every day 15 of the people
who need to be discharged can't be
discharged because the Care Homes won't
take them after 5 00 PM that's at least
70 people a week who could be out of
hospital this is an emergency everyone
was put their their shoulder to the
wheel thank you thank you
on the 8 million pound so the capital
request I know my honorable friend has
raised that uh with me previously it is
something that we are looking at but
she's right in terms of how Capital
needs to be looked at in the contest of
getting flow into a local system and
where the triology can be unlocked on
her point about 5 PM uh I think there's
two points firstly part of the reason
for looking at discharge lounges is if
you have something seven till seven
there's a cultural change for a patient
in going into the discharge Lounge in a
morning and being off the ward and that
is something if you look at other Health
Systems around the world can be very
beneficial in terms of accelerating that
discharge rather than there being a
point in the day after which suddenly
it's easier to leave it to the next day
for the patient to be discharged in
terms of the second one on it with the 5
PM thing is we need to look at what
support the Care Homes themselves need
to have the confidence to take the
patient so I think to be fair to them
it's not simply a question of whether
they themselves using to take the
patient after 5 PM is also about is
looking at the wide wraparound care
package so they're confident at taking
that risk so that they're then not just
after 5 PM on a weekday but also in
particular at weekends when there's
often a significant drop in those
patients being taken Ellen Morgan
um
and it's one of the reasons for the
horrifying ambulance wait times that I
raised in this place on my first day on
the 5th of January 2022 this is not a
new issue for 2023 so I'd like to ask
the minister what is his plan to improve
staff retention because staff
recruitment on its own isn't going to
plug this Gap it hasn't plugged it in
Shropshire and there's no signs of
plugging it across the rest of the
country yeah yeah interested well
firstly we are expanding staff numbers
that's why there's three percent more
doctors than last year why the supers
are more nurses than last year but I
think it's more than simply looking at
that we also need to look at the fact
that we have more elderly patients those
patients are presenting with multiple
conditions that in turn changes the
demands from A system that has
traditionally been more about individual
Specialties into how we're looking at
treating those patients with multiple
conditions and that then needs to be
factored into what skills the workforce
has in other way the point form my
honorable friend is so important about
thinking about roles in terms of what
upskilling can be offered to particular
roles how they can take on a wider set
of responsibility and also the role of
technology in that as well so for
example there are many nurses in
hospitals that currently take time
looking for beds operational control
centers with a different cohort of Staff
as is already the case in some hospitals
not only automates much of that process
Which is far quicker in terms of getting
beds back into use but actually frees up
a lot of nursing time for that to be
used for actually what the nurses would
prefer to be doing which is focusing on
the clinical side and taking them away
from some of those administrative roles
James Wild
thank you so Roger Norfolk and waveney
has already received 11 million pounds
to tackle discharges which is making a
difference however today there are 128
patients in the Queen Elizabeth hostel
and King's Lynn you do not need to be
there so in welcoming this additional
funding don't need pressure is also
underline to the treasury the long-term
importance of investing in modern
hospitals able to meet demand and the
cater including qeh in a new hostels
program
well my uh honorable friend very
skillfully combines both the importance
of discharge at Kings Inn but with the
the importance particularly around the
back hospitals of those uh being
addressed on which he uh has campaigned
assiduously uh as he well knows through
my comments at the NHS provider's speech
it is an issue that uh I very much
recognize I have visited the hospital I
have seen the challenges firsthand and
in my my son was born in that hospital
it's one I know very well we are
discussing that issue with the treasury
and I hope to be in a position to update
the house shortly Roger Bergen thank you
Mr Deputy speaker we won't solve the NHS
crisis without solving the NHS Staffing
crisis and that means sorting out pay
yet today in talks with the unions the
government refused to make a new offer
on pay and the unions say that the
secretary of state is ludicrously
calling do demanding efficiency savings
from nurses and other NHS staff
secretary of state Secretary of State
many of these nurses and NHS staff are
already working 18-hour shifts so when
is the government going to get real when
is going to get serious and when is the
government going to make a proper offer
to NHS staff to avoid strikes
the lead National officer of unite who
is speaking to Sky News outside the
Department of Health just a few minutes
after my discussions with the trade
unions the slightly odd thing was Mr
kasab wasn't actually in the meeting on
which he was commenting
everybody
it's really pleasing actually to hear
from across the house today a focus on
capacity and domiciliary care which
actually is huge priority and ultimately
it's where we want people to end up
independent in their own homes as far as
possible could the Secretary of State
reassure me about some elements of the
plan for the NHS to procure care beds
where does the envisaged staff will come
from and if it's from the NHS themselves
how will we ensure that we don't see
more people leaving domiciliary care for
what are often better paid NHS roles and
in the same vein in terms of capacity
how will we ensure that people are able
to move on from Residential Care beds
into domiciliary care when there is that
shortage of capacity
well he quite rightly as as if it's a
leader of his own County Council
recognizes the importance of that
integration between Health and Care
um as I appointed to the examples
already where that has been done uh
extremely uh effectively in an
integrated way and it is extremely
important I recognize this in my remarks
the the medical director of NHS England
has has said that helping people to
leave hospital with the right support
when they're ready to do so is not just
clinically the best option for these
individuals but one of the safest
options of expanding capacity for
everyone who needs care so it is the
right thing to do clinically but his
point is one we are extremely focused on
is how do we then ensure that there is
the wraparound service for those
patients who are released into
residential care so that again they can
then move into Domino's Jim sham thank
you Mr W speaker can I thank the
minister for that but I know the
Secretary of State appreciates it they
want their pressures are only
exacerbated by looming strikes I I
joined the picket line in Norwich
Hospital sometime back in early December
uh just before Christmas an opportunity
to meet Pat colony leader of the nurses
Union at St Thomas's hospital just
across the bridge as a protest was
ongoing
um today in the news Pat Cullen referred
to a glimmer of hope in relation to to
the the talks that the minister will
have with the nurses those decisions
that believe that real engagement can
take place not simply with the nurses
and midwives but also the junior doctors
who are threatening strikes as well and
does the city of State agree that if it
is not simply about a pay increase but
it's also been increasing the numbers of
staff to secure safety and
accountability on shifts in the
hospitals tonight and every night from
day from night for the day on so to say
well I agree that it's a combination of
pay but also wider conditions that
impacts both the recruitment and
retention that is why uh we have been
very keen to engage constructively with
the trade unions we had a good
discussion uh earlier uh today and he's
recognizing that there are a range of
factors if I take the example of
paramedics uh the feedback from my
discussions with paramedics is actually
what a number of them said to me was
more important to them was pay was their
frustration around the Handover times
and the delays that they were
experiencing in that regard so it is
important to have the discussions uh
through the integrated pay review bodies
uh in terms of pay and what is
Affordable and what is the right balance
but there are also a range of non-pay
factors that are also extremely
important to stuff Philip Oliver the
biggest flu outbreak in 10 years has
seen Kettering General Hospital become
the 28th busiest Hospital in the whole
country with a bed occupancy rate of 96
and a half percent in the week leading
up to New Year the secretary of state
was kind enough to visit Kettering
General Hospital last year he has stood
in the busy and overcrowded a e he was
also good enough to visit Thorndale care
home where he was briefed that the
increase in the number of over 80s
locally in northamptonshire is one of
the fastest growing elderly populations
in the whole country so in thanking the
Secretary of State for the measures that
he's outlined today and the extra
funding will he ensure that
northamptonshire
the north North Hampshire Council the
northamptonshire ICB and crucially
Kettering General Hospital get their
fair share of the funding he's announced
so that we can tackle these winter
pressures quickly and successfully
well he's admitted there is it right to
point to the very real pressures at
Kettering as he says I I I have visited
him and not only am I Keen to see uh
Catherine uh get its fair share I know
through his good offices uh he will
absolutely Champion it as he always does
in terms of ensuring that absolutely is
the case but he also raises I think an
important point which is uh the pressure
from an aging population is not
universally distributed it is more
intense in certain areas than others and
that again is something I'm very keen in
terms of uh sort of scrutiny of the data
that is playing through in some of the
variation in performance between trusts
as I say 50 interests account for 56 of
ambulance Handover delays uh but also
there's very significant variation
across the NHS and understanding what is
driving that such as different aging
profiles between different areas is also
a key part of our recovery
Andy Carter thank you very much Mr
Deputy speaker I spent Friday morning at
Warrington hospital to see for myself
the challenges that the a e Department
staff were facing one senior clinician
said to me it was the busiest he'd seen
in 30 years
the entire hospital was full there were
no beds and on Monday last week 90
people were waiting in a e for a bed
waiting to be admitted now the secretary
of state knows I'm waiting for an
announcement on whether a new hospital
can be funded in Warrington I'm Keen to
hear from him as and when that
announcement will come but can he
reassure my constituents that the
funding announced today will go to
support the staff in Warrington hospital
and the social Care staff in Warrington
to ensure that the pressures that
they're facing both in the hospital and
in Social care will be addressed
immediately
yes I can and that is the whole purpose
of the announcement because uh whilst I
know he campaigns assiduously in respect
of the new hospital I think he will
concede uh regardless of that decision
that would take time and I think there
is an immediate challenge to his point
that the hospital is full around how do
we get additional capacity both into the
emergency department so that that can
operate uh more effectively because if
you have too many people then actually
it impedes the ability of an emergency
department to operate effectively but
also how do we address The Wider
occupancy of the hospital as a whole
because that is core to getting flow
into the system that is a very essence
like him on Friday that is exactly what
we had listened to we have taken on
board the feedback from the clinical
Community particularly within the
emergency departments uh that the
announcement today speaks to the exact
issue that he raises
finally with the prize for patience Sean
Bailey thank you uh last but certainly
not least
um Miss Deputy speaker 700 beds due to
come online thanks to Midlands
Metropolitan Hospital a new Primary Care
Center in wednesbury I'll say tomorrow
what my friend when his department does
deliver we do see the benefits but
clearly that means nothing if we can't
get the processes right and the most
pressing issue at the moment for my
constituents particularly during the
winter has been accessed still to their
GPS and I'm sure members across the
house will agree with me on that so I
welcome what my right humble friend has
said particularly in respect of his use
of technology for example to ensure
people are seeing but fundamentally
people still want face to face
appointments if you're digitally
disconnected you cannot access this as
simple as that so can I ask my right
honorable friend to ensure for his good
office as he stands up and just after he
commits to come to wednesbury to see our
new Primary Care Center that he commits
also to work with GP
where there's best practice particularly
in the black country ICB to ensure that
we can enable those people who are
digitally disconnected to access GPS
so we are firstly working very actively
with the Primary Care Community indeed
that was one of the key focuses of the
prime minister's Summit uh on Saturday
uh in number 10 and it is part of the
work my honorable friend is leading
through the primary care recovery plan I
would say in part in that some patients
continuity care and face-to-face is
extremely important but if you take the
GP patient survey of last year it
suggested that two-fifths of patient
that was extremely important which
suggests for three-fifths actually speed
of access is often often younger patient
is more pertinent but continuity care is
particularly important for those with
multiple conditions particularly more
elderly patients but also alongside that
he raises the the Midlands Hospital he's
absolutely right four years ago when I
was a minister of State in the
department I visited it when it was near
completion and as he knows uh four years
on it's taken a significant amount of
time to then actually get to the opening
stage at and that is why we do need to
look at doing things differently around
value for money and if I look at the the
hospital estate program is why when nine
of the last 10 hospitals were built over
time and overspec we need to look at
modular design modern methods of
construction
standardization which delivers a 35 unit
on unit reduction in cost operational
performance much quicker and enables us
to then get those hospitals up and
running at a far earlier stage so it is
important we do things differently the
new hospital building program is a part
of that but what we have done Mr Deputy
speaker is listen to the front line
listen to those concerns the statement
today addresses the immediate issue of
bed occupancy in hospitals and the
pressure on the emergency departments
all right my thanks to all of those
who've front benches and others who take
the part in a very important discussion
could you now those who wish to leave
the chamber as quickly and quietly as
possible please we need to move on to
the next business
now I come to the statement on energy
business support
um thank you with permission Mr Deputy
speaker I will make a statement on how
this government is continuing to support
businesses Charities and the public
sector